خلال مقابله في احدى البرامج المذاعه على
فضائيه ام بي سي مصر 2 داعي المصري اسامه
قابيل الى ادخال الفرحه في قلوب النساء
قائلا كل سيده تفرحها حتاخد عليها اجر
الداعيه الاسلامي الذي يحث على جبر
الخواطر يعني لو فرحت زوجتك او خالتك او
عمتك او امك حتاخد اجر وثواب وكمان لو
فرحت زميلتك في الشغل هتاخد اجر وثواب
يعني لو عندك زميله جديده لسه بتتعلم
والشغل الشغل وانت علمتها وفهمتها بدل ما
تنكد عليها
وبقت كويسه وفرحت بدها هتاخد اجر وثواب
هذه تصريحات مشاهدينا لقد تفاعلا على
متواصل الاجتماعي في مصر ولا قد استحسانا
خاصه من قبل النساء
[موسيقى]
دكتور طالما احنا في 2023
طيب خليني اقول لحضرتك في البدايه بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحقيقه في عباده جميله جدا اسمها عباده
السعاده والفرح وادخال السرور على قلوب
الناس فحبينا نتكلم عن مفهوم الفرح
والسعاده وجبنا حفيظ سيدنا النبي صلى الله
عليه حضرتي واله افضل الاعمال واحب
الاعمال الى الله تبارك وتعالى سرور
تدخله على مسلم وكمان سيدنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم علمنا يعني احب الاعمال
الى الله تبارك وتعالى ان يكون الانسان في
عون اخيه الانسان فالحقيقه وسعنا دائره
الفهم وخصوصا النهارده احنا في 23 فعايزين
نقول لكل الناس كل الشركات المالتي
والشركات الاجنبيه شركات الخاصه والوظائف
العامه وكل المؤسسات بتجمع ما بين الرجال
والاناث فبتلاقي بعض المعاملات الغير
مقبوله او السلبيه فحبينا نظهر المعنى ده
علشان خاطر نقول للناس ازاي نفرح ونسعد
بعضينا نعم
الحقيقه انا عايز اضيف على حضراتكم
يعني زي كما يقال الاقربون اولى بالمعروف
بدل قبل ما نسعد زميلتنا خلينا نسعد
زوجتنا
صح نعم هل تمارس هذا الموضوع معي في
الحديث دكتور نعم نعم سيدنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم علمنا كلنا خيركم خيركم
لاهله وانا خيركم لاهلي فالانسان يبقى
عنده افضليه وخيريه واحسان وحسن معامله
لان سيدنا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم علمنا
كده ما اكرمهن الا كريم وما اهانهن الا
ليل ولكن احنا بنتكلم النهارده عن مفهوم
اداب واخلاقيات العمل النهارده المجتمعات
العربيه كلها في مصر والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه الامارات العربيه المتحده وكل
المجتمعات العربيه بتنادي بوضع افضل
للمراه ومعامله افضل وتمكين المراه في
الوظائف الاكاديميه والتعليميه والطبيه
والصحيه والاعلاميه وغيرها من الاماكن
اللي علشان ده كان موجود على عهد سيدنا
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واحنا عايشين في
الدنيا علشان كلنا نحاول نسعد بعض يا
اردنا ان نحيا الحياه فعلينا ان نستجيب
لامر الله ودائما بحب اؤكد واقول لكل
الناس حياتنا ملهاش اعاده فلازم نعيشها
بسعاده
[موسيقى]